you guys know i always like to try and
do this so i apologize if it's getting
slightly tiresome but for some of you
maybe lots of you i actually hope you
enjoy this part of the lesson
often in maths you will go do a bunch of
things you draw stuff you write a whole
bunch of symbols and algebra and then
you'll get like something like this
if you haven't got something like this
written somewhere like put like a big
box around it you're like cool i've
proved these results these formulas and
now i can use them however as i
mentioned before right at the top right
being able to use a formula is no
substitute for understanding where it
comes from because that's actually the
thing that matters
i'm pretty confident that the vast
majority of you no actually i take that
back
i'm pretty confident that not one of you
after you leave school is going to need
to go back to these things unless you
become a mathematics teacher explicitly
anyway even those of you who become say
engineers are going to finance or those
kinds of things where you will use these
results all the time you will get a
computer to do these things for you you
do not have to be able to do these by
hand and you might say to me mr wu
why are we wasting our time doing these
then if i'm not going to use them
after school and the answer is you are
just not as these formulas right it's
really the thinking and problem solving
process underneath that really matters
in much the same way that no one's going
to stop you on the street and hold a gun
to your head and say tell me why
macbeth's literary techniques are going
to be the reason why shakespeare is a
part of english history they won't do
that at least i really hope they don't
but as your understanding of text and
characters and plot they will matter and
hopefully those will be things you enjoy
for the rest of your lives
so i want to dig into this one result in
particular because this is the part that
really matters not the formula but the
thinking that goes along with it two
parts number one
you may recall you've got it written
there in your books hopefully i rubbed
it off because i needed some more space
as you can see we pulled this move in
the middle of trying to like there's
like four or five lines of working here
and at a certain point we saw this on
the numerator of the quotient rule do
you remember that and we were like gross
but most of you remembered oh i can
simplify that as one okay now this thing
here
is an important trigonometric identity
but i would like a show of hands and
don't worry i'm not going to ask you to
actually say it i just want an
indication
i'd like a show of hands for who could
who could tell me i won't make you but
who could tell me why this is true
any takers one two
three
okay thank you hands down i'm glad it's
not zero but it's gotta be better than
that so here's what i'd like you to do
with me pick up your pen
and the first thing we're going to do is
understand why this is the case because
it's super important if you're just
using formulas without knowing where
they come from you are not a
mathematician you are just a machine
taking symbols turning them into others
we have better goals higher goals for
you so
if you can draw just a couple of basic
right angle triangles for me
i want you to think about like way back
when you first met
the trigonometric ratios in fact we
called them ratios not functions because
they were about comparing sides and a
right angle triangle that's what ratios
are divide this thing by that thing okay
so i just want you to rehearse with me
each one of these sine cos and tan is a
ratio in a right angled triangle
you even have a whole mnemonic for it
right sokatoa what is sine
something over something what is it
it's
opposite on hypotenuse right and you can
keep the soccer tower going cos is going
to be
adjacent or hypotenuse and then lastly
10 is
opposite on adjacent toe okay great
now we can visually represent this on
our right angle triangle by saying
if here's the theta here's the angle
we're interested in opposite's over here
adjacent's here and there's the
hypotenuse okay now where this result
comes from is the result of asking a
very simple question which is
this hypotenuse here
what if we had a hypotenuse
that was equal to one
what would that look like
is that important well let's see when
you do sine and cos and that's actually
all we will need for this one when you
do sine
instead of just saying opposite on
hypotenuse you can say it's opposite
this side divided
well i've just said like what if the
hypotenuse is 1.
so it's just 1.
do you see what i just did there if the
denominator is 1 then the sine is equal
to the opposite side so instead of
writing opposite i'm just going to write
sine here is that okay
sine is that's weird because we would
normally think of this as like something
to do with an angle but it's a length
now right same deal with cos
if the hypotenuse is 1 then what is cos
equal to
it's
a over 1 which i guess you could just
write a right that's the adjacent side
so that's cos
down here
now if you look at this and you apply
pythagoras to it you get the result that
we looked at before right a squared plus
b squared
equals c squared or i mean you can write
it whichever order you'd like right a
squared plus
b squared there's the sum of the squares
of the two shorter sides
equals the square of the hypotenuse
which in this case is
just one
and that's where the result comes from
it is essential that you know not just
that things are
but why things are so that's the first
thing i wanted to pull out
the second one i did ask you to put your
laptop down before you could put it up
for this part if you wanted but i'm
going to show you everything you need to
i'm just going to ask this question like
we got this result
and my question to all of you is
and
like so why should i care what does that
even mean what does it look like right i
want to show you why and again we're
going to do this just the way we did
with signing calls why visually when you
look at this thing
you have to end here there's nowhere
else you could go right so let's have a
think about what is that sec squared x
it's a reciprocal function what's the uh
what's sec the reciprocal of
it's cos right
so let's put cos on here hopefully you
can see that right
now it's not just cos that we have it's
actually cos
squared that ended up on the denominator
right cos squared so just
look at it for a moment again think
visually
what's going to happen to this and i'll
just um i'll restrict it just a little
bit to make it easier to see
what's going to happen to this thing
when you square it
when you square this graph what would it
even look like
well you can think about some of the
values like see this one one squared is
one so when you square this you'll be
going through there
uh this is zero down here zero squared
is
zero so you're going to be there
what's this value down here vertically
it's it's negative one right can you see
it sorry it's not the most obvious but
my ipad's in the way for some of you but
negative 1 squared negative 1 times
negative 1 is
1. so you're going to be back up here
so you're sort of like here and then
here and then you back up here somehow
and then there's this symmetry to it so
does it make sense to you
that if you were to take not cows if you
take cos x and then
square it
you should get something like that
looks weird but are you okay with why it
is what it is you can see it's all
positive because it was squared the
spots that were 0 become 0 the spots
that were 1 and negative 1 become 1.
so now we want to go from this to
its reciprocal this is cos squared
this is 1 divided by
that i'm going to get rid of this one
right there's cos squared now that we're
focusing on okay
again have a think
1 divided by
this
what's 1 divided by one
one what's one divided by a half
one divided by half is two what's one
divided by zero
uh oh we got problems there right so
whatever this graph is going to look
like it's gonna be it's to have some
weird spots okay so now i'm going to go
1 divided by
is cos x
squared
that guy's weird
but does it make sense can you see why
like there's a spot one that you told me
one divided by one with one here's a
half in fact i can even prove it if i go
x equals 0.5 there it is
and you can see right there
no sorry not x equals 0.5 i want oh how
am i going to do this i think it's like
0.7 ish
that's not bad there you go i'm getting
closer there
i didn't get exactly on half sorry about
that so you can see it's this weird
shape to it why why does it like why is
there a break here do you remember why
there was a break i asked you this point
down here
x equals zero you can't divide by zero
right so in fact there's an asymptote
going right up through here okay so this
is what
that is
sec squared
how is that
the derivative of tan
are you ready here comes the quencher
let's put 10 on
all right there's a lot going on here so
let's restrict it a little bit so you
can see
i reckon
that'd be enough
zero x
okay
huh it's not restricting the way that oh
because i typed it on the wrong spot
because you're an idiot that's better
ah there we go
you're also patient thank you all right
that's more like it
look at the tan curve it's the one in
black can you see it and we've seen the
tan curve before i didn't ask you to
draw it but have a look at it there it
is it's familiar i hope
when you draw it in there
it's got this upward curve what does
that mean for the gradient
the gradient should be positive right so
that's why this green graph is always
positive
the lowest that the green graph goes is
one and that's because when you have a
look at a spot like say there
right there that's a gradient of one you
could do the same thing with your ruler
that we did earlier on and place that
there and there and you get a gradient
of one
but the rest of the gradient
well tell me when you have a look at
this tan graph right what can you tell
me about the gradient when you move
towards the right
does the gradient get bigger or smaller
it gets bigger it's like steeper and
steeper and steeper forever and that's
why this gradient the green graph gets
higher and higher and higher does that
make sense
so this is not just what the algebra
gives you it's what the picture tells
you and that's the important part of
this okay